I'm returning my red iPhone and this red
case now before you did the specifics of
why a lot of people I was actually quite
surprised in the comments had no idea
that red is actually a charity and
they've been around for quite a while a
husband partnering to them for 10 years
and this phone was actually I think
their 10 year celebration of working
with them
adilyn total has donated 130 million
dollars to the red foundation the entire
charity has raised four hundred sixty
five million which makes one of their
leading donors now I have no idea what
the specifics are of percentages of the
iPhone sales or cases or how that all
works technically this phone is for
charity and I don't know how much of
that is actually going to read and
you're not familiar with red as a
charity at all it's an HIV and AIDS
prevention treatment counseling and they
also have a very specific focus on
eliminating transmission from mom to
child which it's kind of powerful and
Here I am buying a silly iPhone for the
sake of the color granted yes I did know
that a portion of those going to charity
which that's absolutely incredible but
then I'm thinking well now I'm returning
it so does that mean that I'm taking
that little bit of a percentage away
from the charity that I just technically
sort of donated to yeah and for a very
silly superficial reason and the reason
that I'm returning it is simply because
I just realized that I don't like the
color red at all I like it as sort of an
accent color to things but just as a
simple colour in whole lemon graphic
designer for quite a long time so I
absolutely involves colors and I love
kind of the way that different colors to
make people feel and red does not make
me have a very good feeling at all I
just I do not like it I was looking at
my Instagram feeds my YouTube thumbnails
after the past couple of days of me
making videos about the phone and it
just hit me I was like this phone do not
actually make me happy my jet black zone
made me really happy it still makes me
happy and I really liked it and it's a
perfectly great phone so this is what I
decided to do I decided to return the
phone and then donate the entire
proportion of what I paid for the phone
to red so I think that's a much better
use of the money that I paid for this
phone I mean I bought this phone so I'll
get that money back and then I'm
right simple as that I wish that I knew
what percentages it actually went to
charity but now at least I know that
basically 100% of what I paid for this
is now going to actually help people
that is my reason on why I'm returning
it is simply because I don't like the
color and it's creating I ran into a
bunch of people who saw my video and
they were so excited to show me their
phone so good guy and I was like it
looks good it looks incredible also I
want to address a lot of you guys so
Justin just get a clear case then that
will alleviate the problem of you being
able to see to the phone's color
I don't like clear cases at all I've had
them before I've had them in the past
with traveling it's going to create
these shoots random destinations I never
really know where I'm going to end up
from a day-to-day basis I can just tell
you that clear cases get really
disgusting stuff get stuck in between it
and it gets trapped there so not only
are you looking at your phone but you're
looking at all of the dirt that your
phone has come in contact and it is
trapped in there and it is not a pretty
sight correct me if I'm wrong or if you
guys have a case that is clear and
perfect and no dirt gets in let me know
what it is because that's a magical case
I also feel so bad because I made that
video and then a bunch of my friends
will let you see and I got the red phone
cuz he said it was so cool it is cool I
think this is an absolutely beautiful
thought it is it looks so good I just
don't like the color red like this
everything else about it
I love to so you already know that I
like the phone that's nothing new
I am keeping the other end case that I
got and the Apple watch band because
they match perfectly so this is it and
make me happy so I would much rather
take that money that I have and
hopefully change somebody else's life
and make somebody else way more happy
than this film could have baby that's it
I see you guys later hope you guys have
a great day
I'm going to return this now yes the new
update is called Apple file system a PFS
for short this is originally I think
announced last year at WWDC so they're
just now integrating it into the 10-3
update which is pretty exciting and it
looks like guess what my phone is ready
thank you so we already talked about
finding my air pods and we're going to
try that out in just a second power play
update which I am so excited about